[Music]
okay so this is my review of the highly
anticipated Breaking Bad movie
El Camino now here's my thing first off
is that I am someone who is never that
excited when I hear about a TV show
becoming a movie I never get why people
get so excited about this fascination
with it I mean this goes just back even
to like the entourage movie where people
go oh wow they're gonna do a movie of it
but it's one of those things where I'm
always like well technically it's just a
long episode of the show and usually the
show just works great it has a show and
that's what makes it so special then
when you transfer it to a movie it
always just inevitably feels like just
two episodes of the show and this
clearly felt like that a lot and just
kind of like an epilogue but it felt
didn't it did not feel like a movie so
that was disappointing in the sense that
I was excited to see what Vince Gilligan
could do here Vince Gilligan is one of
those people that with him directing and
writing it I'm always trusting him I
don't ever think he chips his audience
and I think if he's gonna do something
he knows it's going to be good or
they're wise he won't do it but the case
here was I thought he would give us what
a Breaking Bad movie would be where it
feels like a movie that it's a little
more intense and it kind of just felt
like two extended bonus episodes of
Breaking Bad just focusing on Jesse's
part of the story and unfortunately this
is the first time I felt like oh no like
Vince Gilligan's the one creator I trust
always not to sell his soul at all but
this did feel a little bit like a money
grab and that is unfortunate and I have
a couple reasons for that
so first off you're seeing in this movie
things that is uncharacteristic of
anything in the Breaking Bad universe
where they always do a good job of not
doing something cheesy or corny or you
roll your eyes first off seeing Todd in
these flashbacks and
looking a completely different person
the actors you know he his whole
appearance is different now he looks
like a complete different person from
the todd we knew which you can kind of
get away with if you hide him a bit or
just show him a little bit but to have
him as a main player in this movie was
really distracting and takes me out of
it and some people say oh they're fine
with it they got used to it but for the
standards of this Breaking Bad universe
they don't do gimmicky stuff like that
and this just felt like wow this is
asking a lot of the audience to just
kind of go with that also goes to when
you get the reveal of Walter White which
was expected it was gonna be in a
flashback I was sure that was the safest
route it made sense but you got Bryan
Cranston we're in this ridiculous bald
cap and it's like making his head look
like a conehead I'm like what the hell
like how did Vince even go through with
that that annoyed me as well and I get
it's still in the TV realm so there
knows not much time to prepare for it
they probably get in these actors last
minute for certain scenes but don't do
it then so that's where it feels like a
money grab to me where you're like
alright we'll still just push through
with it and get this done and that was
frustrating so I'm usually not someone
who complains about when they extend
stories or try to make prequels I get it
and people who love a universe want to
see more and understand that but better
call Saul to me has always felt like
it's still its own thing and it's earned
it and I haven't feel gypped but this
feels like it's not its own thing it
feels like an extension of Breaking Bad
yes to bring about a movie but it
doesn't keep the high standards of
Breaking Bad so that's where it feels
like it's just a poor man's version of
it and that's really disappointing not
saying this was all bad though so
basically I think that obviously the
goal of Jesse's story here from the end
of Breaking Bad where we saw him to now
is that his whole arc in Breaking Bad is
this is a guy who he's not always in
control of his life really ever and this
was angling that this would be the film
that gets him his closure there where he
finally takes control of his life
something Jesse's never able to do and
that's shown with the flashback at the
end where he's with Jane and that was a
nice moment and then him driving
often to the snow in Alaska was really
nice because it just had great symmetry
with the end of Breaking Bad where
Jesse's driving off into the desert and
it's a totally different situation but
it still even felt a little cheesy just
the white turtleneck almost was just
like corny and it was a little too on
the nose I get they love using their
color themes here but it's like all
right when he was coming out of the
truck with the white on fine I was like
come on this is we've seen this in so
many shows and it's it's not as clever
as it thinks it is so that kind of felt
like a step off for Gilligan there
and then when it comes to Aaron Paul I
thought he did really well here I saw
some people actually criticizing his
acting at Jesse's younger ages but I
thought he nailed it especially in the
diner scene or Jesse was still goofball
and just eating the food hysterically I
thought that scene worked with Walter
White but it still was just like a
fanservice moment especially with them
walking down the hallway which always
talking about mean bait there you go
there's your mean bait for this movie
where people share that picture like I
got chills or this was amazing what
really was it like what was the what was
that scene actually really doing was it
necessary no it wasn't it was the reason
to get Walter White in a flashback and
sure you had a line and with Walter
White making saying how he wishes he was
like Jesse where he got to do what he
loved it earlier in age but it's like oh
cool so it's just confirming that but we
knew that you know that's that's not
great TV or film whatever want to call
it like these are things the audience
can make on their own and just having it
serve to us here was kind of like yeah
and that's the whole thing about this
movie is it's kind of what you predicted
in your head just thinking about what
this movie would be about and where
Jesse's story might go to me it was safe
the shootout scene that was the Western
thing again a little cheesy it was cool
but even the character here from Katie
welding they introduced he was a little
over-the-top and cartoony as well so I
don't know I I wasn't feeling it to be
honest I mean it just felt extra extra
slow at parts especially the first hour
was kind of like what am I watching here
it looked really nice the cinematography
was great like the scenes with the
overhead shots of the apartment was
really brilliant with the cinematography
there
that but man it was there at an
apartment for a long time with Jesse and
even the flashbacks of Todd were long
and it was way too much Todd screentime
he's got comic relief to his character
he's a psychopath yeah it's funny seeing
him singing a happy song when he's
driving to go bury a dead body or saying
that he wanted to say words for the
cleaning lady great but it's it's just
replaying notes you've seen before these
characters it was just giving people
what they wanted to see with seeing
characters again but I just thought it
would be a stronger story and giving
super justification of why we're here
again and it did not feel that way that
is what really upsets me here and
there's like parts to where wait a
minute in this universe they're always
good with character consistency and
believable points and transitions and
how they go from one just character we
know and grow and evolve to another
where they go the other way but jesse
was introduced in this movie as someone
who was obviously seriously under
serious trauma being in a cage and
tortured and acting that way in the
beginning at skinny Pete's place and
he's looking up and he's imagining being
that cage again and that was very
realistic of what someone be going
through but all of a sudden he shaves
and takes a shower and that stuff's kind
of gone it's Jesse's kind of got his
composure really fast in this movie and
that's another problem with shows that
are good with developing characters and
convincing arcs movies you can't really
do that as well and that suffered here
because it was just like a wow this was
a quick flip for Jesse in two hours so
as a Breaking Bad fan that also was
disappointing and that's what's gonna
have really happen when if we start
making movies like this so I don't think
it was totally earned with Jesse coming
full circle at the end and being this
more almost awakened version of himself
and taking control of his life where I
mean just a couple days ago he's just
someone full of trauma here and going
through that stuff so it was a lot again
to just have us believe here
it was nice the beginning with skinny
Pete and badger I thought that worked
well I thought that that was a little
more interesting it was more funny to
was a nice touch with skinny Pete where
he said that jesse was his hero cool
worked but again that middle part here
that
half-hour mark we got two in the movie
to the hour and half was who snoozefest
man and I wasn't at the edge of my seat
at all until that little showdown with
the western gunpoint thing but even that
I was like aah and it was promoted this
movie like it would be kind of this car
chasing and a little more intense even
the beginning it starts that way and
he's gonna get rid of this car but it's
really not that much about the car the
El Camino and it was kind of weird that
they set up skinny Pete Minh we don't
see him again with the car what happened
him in badger I thought that was odd
yeah it just it didn't feel as much of
an effort was put into this as I thought
it would be especially of how long we've
waited in Vince gillum's Vince
Gilligan's hinted about this so again
there's funny moments I mean I thought
the funniest part was Todd having
seeing his bedroom when he has a snow
globe model of him with Lydia and his
obsession with her that was great but if
I'm watching something from the universe
and a standard of a creator director
writer I'm just not used to men skilling
and having things happen where again
Jesse Plemons is clearly not in the
physical realm of being the Todd he once
was so that is just absurd to me they
kept with that and same with the bald
cap with Walter and you could say it's
nitpicking whatever but no this is
Breaking Bad this is not supposed to be
like that this isn't one of those shows
and that's just incredibly disappointing
to me I don't come to the show for any
of that I don't want to see anything
that's a cheap like that and that
started happening here so yeah and I
just didn't feel high stakes in this at
all and it was just kind of cut and dry
here where it started where it got it
was a simpler story than you would might
have expected and even the Easter eggs
you can watch those videos on YouTube
they're everywhere then okay you know
they're not crazy good and you know it's
nice they had the the frames in the
office of Hank and his partner that was
cool it was cool to see that you know
the chicken place was shut down those
are nice but everything else was like
yeah okay cool nice whatever shoving
Walter Roy in flashbacks let's do mostly
fat flashbacks and just felt thin so for
me I'm going to say from being a huge
fan of Breaking Bad and also a supporter
of better call Saul I'm really enjoying
that and
during that show this is the first
actual clear disappointment for me from
the vince gilligan brain trust here in
his universe it's the first thing in the
Breaking Bad universe I actually just
didn't really like so as a Netflix movie
it's better than a lot of Netflix movies
and sure if you love Breaking Bad give
it a watch but otherwise I don't know I
think it was a it was a ended with that
feeling I was afraid of where I was like
was this necessary and it wasn't it just
was not it was just it was fanfiction
and you can say it wasn't but it was
and that's the disappointment there so
I'm giving this one a seven point seven
let me know you throw this one down
below maybe you loved it I've seen a lot
of debate about this a lot of people
don't like it at all I see people
praising it too high I see people
destroying it unrightfully sokka's eight
such high spec tations I just think it's
more of a middle like yeah and I don't
want to watch it again and it's just
disappointing again because of the
stakes of this show so yeah seven point
seven for me let me know I'm really
interested to hear your thoughts on this
I read every comment try to respond as
many as I can
please subscribe to my channel so you
don't miss one of my reviews of TV's
movies as to do celebrity interviews as
well so you don't miss that and follow
me at Steve rd1 on Twitter and scan her
for more of me and I'll see you next
time